I was just a goofball as kids so I
actually wanted to be a comedic actor I
think that was one thing my mom always
wanted for me she always wanted me to
follow my dreams as anyone in here ever
wanted to get worse at something
I think probably in that moment I knew
that this is what I was going to do
forever you know the real inspiration
comes from just the pleasure of doing
things
you know if you get too focused on
competitions sometimes and you don't
have anything else happening then you
get lopsided I had many many years where
I had all my energy strictly going into
trying to improve my surfing win heats
and that was my laser focus you know if
you're not getting better
then it's not fun anymore you know
that's my that's my theory I guess a
measure of success is you know the end
result I'm not a religious person I
don't even know if I believe in God but
it was a gift from God it was like this
he's an American professional surfer
known for his competitiveness and style
he's been crowned world surf league
champion a record 11 times in 2007 he
became the all-time leader in career
event wins he's Kelly Slater and here
are his top ten rules for success
surfing is in its most basic sense just
a true freedom of expression I was just
a goofball as kids that I actually
wanted to be a comedic actor up until
town was about ten years old
while surfing has really defined my life
on probably every level in some way I
believe in certain people there's just
this built-in desire and drive to win
that's sort of beyond what other people
can understand
I come from a small city in Florida in
Central Florida and there's not too many
people in my city who sort of spread out
around the world night I live around the
world I travel around the world and it's
it's really great it's a lot of fun but
I think as a kid I had a lot of ideas
that were really big and both my parents
had passions that they never really
followed my both my parents love to play
music dad play guitar my mom loved to
sing and play banjo my dad did a little
bit of statical acting and but they
never really followed their dreams
neither one of them you know and I think
that was one thing my mom always wanted
for me she always wanted me to follow my
dreams and to think big don't you know
don't just think of like you know just a
little problem you have at school or
just a little I mean you got to take
care of those things too but it's
thinking about the you know someone like
that all I long he's thinking about the
whole world every time he makes a
decision you know and and if people
think if more people think that way more
big great things happen
this room
has anyone in here ever wanted to get
worse at something I mean if you're
trying to get better you're competitive
whether it's with yourself or with
someone else some people try to get
tried trying to get more better does
that make sense
I mean I like mo bettah that's a lot
better better better honor but Rob and I
were both raised in very competitive
homes Rob's dad made made the Malloy
brothers two father break a ping-pong
paddle and cry one time in his own home
this is not a joke no it was serious
actually through the paddling broke the
wall screaming cussing I heard ya but
Rob's dad and his older brother like
crazy crazy competitive guys like they
always how I always knew them hanging
out when we were teenagers you know like
Jim would beat us at tennis and then he
was way better than us at golf and he
would like take us through the golf
range we were hitting balls and you'd be
like the hell are you doing that looks
terrible that's awful
hey just like berated like just it kind
of he was constantly pushing that button
and it wasn't it never was like mean it
well it was mean but it was nice yeah it
was like it was always out of love
because Jim just wanted us to see better
I wanted to see how to be better at
things and he loved I think your dad
really loved that competitive
environment and being a part of it and
just experiencing it
the wave I rode I think I was eight
years old
that wave stands out in my head probably
more than any wave in my life for some
reason it it wasn't any sort of amazing
wave it was a just a little wave
probably you know wasted chest-high
I took off on it and I just did I did it
bottom turn and I did a little turn off
the top and I just did that three
different times and when I finished the
third one I came down I started
straighten off on the way when I looked
over my dad was smiling at me and right
at that moment it was just such sheer
joy you know like connecting with my dad
but also finding the thing that like I
was becoming good at I think probably in
that moment I knew that this is what I
was going to do forever
and I was inspired to go travel around
the world I wanted to be able to make
money and travel around the world and
surf all these great tropical places and
but at the end of it all after going all
these places for so many years and doing
so many things that you know the real
inspiration comes from just the pleasure
of doing things just from from you know
it doesn't have to be the best or
biggest or most exciting Waiver journey
or whatever it's still it really comes
down to sharing with people you know
having time with with your friends and
your family the people you love
most of things I do are things I enjoy
and you know kind of fulfills my life
and some things make me busy and can
distract me so I got to you know make
sure I don't do too many of those and
you know if you get too focused on
competitions sometimes you don't have
anything else happening then you get
lopsided you know and I've done that
before
and I don't I don't really want to go
back in that direction you know you got
to structure things your own way
take advice it's going to help you and
structure it your own way and I I just I
feel like generally I can maintain what
I do and focus on the competition too
I've been really you know no excuse I've
put in 100% effort in you know when I've
served Heath's
last couple years but I have been
especially in the last year been very
distracted by a lot of other stuff and
just I had many many years where I had
all my energy strictly going into trying
to improve my surfing win heats and that
was my laser focus and you know last
couple years been a little bit more
business and side things and and also
you know just a slight lack of the same
amount of interest you know it's not as
exciting after all these years and stuff
you know
I mean you I don't know what you felt
the end of your career but you know at
some point you start kind of going well
okay I've been here of Dinah out of surf
against this guy I know what's the new
excitement in that
I'm super inspired it get better at
surfing you know if you're not getting
better then it's not fun anymore like
you know that's my that's my theory
so getting worse at something you might
as well find something else that you can
get good at I had an idea of how one of
the surf waves and I wanted to be able
to do that and I didn't see really
anyone who surf that way you know the
way I thought
Oh
when you're forming an idea when you
have a vision whether it's music or it's
a company or technology you know you you
have people thinking about it that are
coming up with brainstorming all these
great ideas and then it starts to get
bigger and then you need people who can
reach out in those different branches
and grab the right people and I think
that's where the success comes in you
got to have that like mind but then you
have to have different ideas and
different viewpoints and and I guess the
measure of success is you know the end
result whatever comes in the end
I was in Fiji just a month after he died
I was surfing in this event the waves
were absolutely perfect and I just was
sitting there while I was surfing the
heat and decided daydreaming about my
dad and I just gosh my dad's never
surfed one wave as good as any of these
waves out here and all of a sudden this
wave came and it was it was I'm not a
religious person I don't even know if I
believe in God but it was a gift from
God it was like this and I took off on
it and I you know that for people don't
know about surfing the ultimate thing is
to get a barrel get inside the tube and
I I think I pulled in the barrel for
about 10 12 seconds on this wave or
something and it was right I swear 15
seconds after I had this thought in my
head about like I wish like my dad could
catch one of these waves and then that
wave came and I came out at wave and I
just like pointed at the sky and and it
was like I knew my dad was there with me
it was almost like that wave that I got
when I was eight years old you know
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Julia Beatriz
Schmidt asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Kelly's top 10 rules had
the biggest impact on you leave in the
comments and I'll join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon